I turn to my right right now and he's
got a statue outside of staples but he's
gonna be at the forum in Inglewood this
weekend Golden Boy Productions Golden
Boy promotes the first-ever MMA show at
the forum and it's none other than Chuck
Liddell vs. Tito Ortiz the final
installment of the trilogy and none
other than the Golden Boy himself
Oscar De La Hoya back here on the show
good to see you sir I should have
brought my six kids I would love an
aizen's Shuster De La Hoya played there
you go that would be fantastic as long
as I can roll that Turkey where's that
by the way you are going to did you know
that I bowled 286 my score 286 10
strikes no 9 strikes in a row ok so I
hold on a sec I don't know about a
turkey but so did you miss the strike in
frame 1 or 10 it was the last one I
choked
so usually strolling to the strike for a
perfect 300 yeah I got confident yeah
and now do you are you one of those
boulders where you gotta have your own
ball your own shoes I actually had
actually had shoes bag to balls I was
pretty so you're real I was die hard
yeah it was pretty good so you don't
blow you know I was because I
practically lived in Big Bear in the
mountains where I trained so the only
thing to do is talk to the trees or Bowl
and so I decided to bowl pretty good at
it it's a much more healthy endeavor to
talk to trees in fact do you miss
fighting at all every day of my life
really every day of my life and that was
an answer what do you miss then um I
actually miss getting hit come on yeah I
missed getting hit because that that
feeling of retaliation you know that
that buildup of like I'm gonna like I'm
gonna kick your you know behind there I
haven't felt that ever since I retired
you know so you gotta be hit and
wondered yeah you got to be hit to to
retaliate to hit somebody back to to
that anger and I missed that you missed
that I miss it every single day of my
life would you like one of us to hit you
in the face hit people but I mean I
would you know I'm sure I wouldn't do
anything I mean look believe it or not
I've never been in the street fight at
all zero outside of the ring that Olay
yeah I always refused to fight for free
so people don't mess with you do they
and all the time like what give me an
example yeah like I mean like that's it
you're the champ I mean like you know
guys that are like six five to 60 you
know tough guys yeah yeah just trying to
throw down exactly exactly but I tend to
I tend to talk my way out of it it's
interesting with a talker
it's a hospital I know you are and
you're obviously a great promoter too as
well as an old-time goat champion you
know it's funny I had Tyson on this show
couple years ago and we used to have a
commercial break a quick 60-second
commercial break in the middle of of the
hour and I would do an interview to
start it and then take a break and
finish it and that break came in very
handy when I asked Mike Tyson how many
rounds he could give me now and he looks
at me he goes I don't want to answer
that question because when I think of
boxing I go to a dark place and thankful
I'm like okay well let's take a break
let's change the soul come back yeah and
we'll talk some more yeah so there's no
there's no dark place for you no no
there's no Thorat there's a happy place
actually you know for some reason when I
got in the ring I actually it would make
me happy it really would it's it was my
escape
you know of getting hit hitting somebody
it was just it was my it was my place to
where I felt you know me for once you
know
no I felt real where I felt where I felt
as if I belonged you know you don't feel
that way outside of the way not to get
too deep into it right well you know it
takes it takes some take some take some
you know some strength to to build up
that that inner in there feeling I had
inside the ring is that why you're in
promotions right now
yeah well it's keeping me it's keeping
me I guess you know involved in the game
when I sit down ringside and watch these
fights I'm constantly telling myself oh
I can take these guys on I could you
know back into this and I should have
knocked them out so it keeps me in the
game you know it's like yeah sure cuz
you know I sit and watch I'm fortunate
to do what I do for a living and I sit
and watch football games with Hall
Famers like right you know I did it for
years with Marshall Faulk and and and
they're the same way they look at it
they go come on like come on you gotta
make that throw right talk about this
with some Pro Bowlers you know like some
all-time greats like how do you not see
this come on like this guys I could do a
little bit better right exactly
so with the salaries that these guys are
getting paid right now - yeah right you
know it's it's the the the game has
changed
mmm amazingly it's it's changed it's
it's it's how has it changed in your
mind um well I remember when I used to
fight I mean my fights were exciting you
know weird word I would throw like a ten
punch combination like you don't see
that anymore you know why do you think
you mentioned it it's the money you know
it's it's it's there's there's too much
money involved there for fighters don't
want to take the risk you know you know
I'm saying it's smart but come on give
us some entertainment you know I want to
see a knock-down I'm sitting somebody
knocked out so you you would go and you
would go into the ring Oscar De La Hoya
here on the Richard show thinking I've
got to give these people oh yeah
their money's worth tonight yeah it was
it was the fight first and then I
understood that the money will follow
you know or the business would follow
for today it's like okay let me do the
most business and you know maybe give
him a good fight if it happens so you
said you were happiest when you're
retaliating in the ring who are you
happiest to retaliate against the most
Oscar I would have to say see that's a
tough one I fought this kid who was
local named Fernando Vargas okay he was
from Oxnard I believe and
he was he was talking so much smack yeah
he was talking so much smack and and and
this this this guy genuinely like just
didn't like me for some strange reason
so it was it was kind of like the
villain and the good guy right but he
was talking so much and I remember man I
can't wait to get my hands on him I
cannot wait to get my hand and he
actually almost knocked me out in the
first round he had me through the ropes
and I was holding on for dear life and
some for some reason I survived it and I
ended up knocking him out in the 11th
so buddy you can imagine in between the
fight was just brutal it was it was a
pretty cool fight no kidding yeah and
now again Golden Boy Promotions with the
first ever MMA show at the forum what do
you like about Chuck Liddell and Tito
Ortiz would you like about this I like
the history the history involved with
with both guys I think I think the fact
that these two guys are pioneers they're
they're icons of the UFC when you think
about the UFC you think about Tito Ortiz
and Chuck lie down there in the Hall of
Fame
yeah they're in the Hall of Fame and so
when this opportunity presented itself I
I jumped on it right away
I had to be part of it um when I started
Golden Boy Promotions
about 18 years ago 18 yeah 18 years ago
already I was thinking about that yeah
um time flies it's you're done yeah time
flies I actually had somebody paint my
beard here cuz it's it's actually a
white well you know I don't mean I don't
mean to I guess I'm thinking how did
that happen where the time go like right
I have kids that are 20 years old Wow
you know and so yeah time flies and so
anyway I started Golden Boy Promotions
I remembering I had a bed up at a in the
hotel and one of those ballrooms maybe
500 people no TV yes and and look at
where we're at now you know and so I
think about my first MMA show on
pay-per-view
sold-out arena at the at the forum yeah
with Chuck lie down Tito Ortiz I just I
like my odds I like my odds it's gonna
be a lot of fun again you the
pay-per-view is gonna be featured on
ring tv.com or WW fight which is f ite
dot TV for $39.99 beginning at 9:00
Eastern six o'clock right here local
forum time in a series of undercard
ballots are gonna be streamed on the
golden boy fight night Facebook
beginning at 7:00 Eastern four o'clock
out here Pacific time so if you had the
opportunity to do what Floyd did which
was fight an MMA guy late in a career
would you have done that I don't know I
don't know I don't think I would have no
i i i i respect boxing too much you know
and MMA and you know vice versa right
it's it's i mean i didn't i actually
haven't seen the fight but from what I'm
told it just wasn't a real fight you did
not see the flow I haven't seen him I
haven't seen races just on principle it
just out of the stuff to do or just that
I
I already knew the outcome I mean
McGregor is great at what he does in the
Octagon and Floyd Mayweather is great at
what he does in the ring so I mean take
McGregor pass what four or five rounds
and and and he's uh he's a target he's
he's he has no conditioning to go six
seven eight nine rounds and that's
exactly what that's what I did he - deep
waters and stop them in a 10th round as
opposed to just giving a puncher's
chance to this guy in the first yeah
three minutes right Floyd doesn't do
that he doesn't I love that by the way I
love the look on your face right now so
you know I don't want to put words in
your mouth do you not a risk-taker is
that what I'm saying no he's he's he's a
very he's very calculated and he's been
very smart I mean if you're into the
business first right he's done it right
Oscar De La Hoya a few more minutes left
here with you what's it like when you go
to Staples and see you or statue out in
front of it what does that mean to you
man it's I still I still have to like
pinch myself
I still have to I still have to like
think about it and say wow I mean what
did I do to deserve this you know but
then I start thinking about all the kids
who walk up to it to take pictures you
know who who are dreamers and maybe one
day they want to have a statue you know
so so that statue there has its purpose
you know it's it's like it's it's it's
it's motivating it's it's it's it's it's
a statue that can that can basically
literally change lives I mean if I'm a
kid and I see a statue of you know my
hero mm-hmm I want to be like that hero
I want to win world titles I want to be
you know iconic I want to be that
champion you know so so I sometimes
think about how I don't deserve it but
at the same time I have to realize that
uh you know it's it's it's it's
basically changing lives for for these
young kids who are who are believers and
dreamers are you do you go to Lakers
games I mean you go often okay I did
look at what you think it LeBron coming
back here what do you think these
challenges right now I think I think the
challenge is is it's just acclimating to
to to his surroundings you know
including the atmosphere the fans and
especially his team yes I think I think
we're gonna we're gonna win several
World titles you really do you're not
just saying that cuz you out there now
thanks to magic and Kareem I mean if I
say the opposite I mean they might take
my side I like it but it is it you know
again it's amazing how Los Angeles gets
blessed every now and then with all time
it's time goats all right like that
like the Kobe out - a couple years later
here comes LeBron and it's still
difficult for me to adjust seeing him in
like any Laker uniform as he goes back
to it's it's a night it happens in every
sport I mean you had Muhammad Ali mm-hmm
Mike Tyson Sugar Ray Leonard Julio Cesar
Chavez yes myself
Floyd Pacquiao every 10 15 years you
hear about or you see this figure coming
you know up the ranks and and and
becoming this iconic figure you know
same thing with basketball it's like I
think it's time now mm-hmm well in terms
of redemption would you care for a shot
of redemption in the Rock'em Sock'em
robots I would that you beat me I think
that if you see over the edge right
there
um the Rock'em Sock'em robots but still
this is that it's still set up the very
same way last when you were here of your
robot having its head popped up because
you just I took I took into deep waters
I went three men I took you in deep
waters and there it has ever seen it
right there Wow back on in 2017 now as a
good promoters do I need to set the
terms do I do I need to hold you over a
barrel here get Redemption that should I
should I just as a business man you tell
me should I should I hold it over you
should I you know what I actually we
should just keep it that way
really thing huh I mean I mean I just
talked out of that's the one motion ever
that's your claim to fame come on
see he's too good a try he said like
five minutes ago he was a great talker
and he talks his way out of fights with
bigger dudes I would keep it that way
that's like your claim to fame so here's
what we'll do we'll leave it like that
for your next time in the meantime I
want you to Turkey Bowl since you said
you bowled a 300 most 300 before I was
like 15 years ago okay we'll see if you
still have a little rusty I love it when
you come here man I love it when you
come here so please come over often
Thank You Oscar - Oscar De La Hoya on
Twitter again check out the first ever
MMA show at the beautiful new spankin
redone forum right here in Los Angeles
next door to the future home of the Rams
and chargers something that is going to
be something else at Chuck Liddell
against Tito Ortiz it's gonna be done at
9:00 Eastern Time 6 p.m. Pacific coming
up on Saturday and I make it part of
your very busy sports Thanksgiving
weekend grab a Thanksgiving right back
at you Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience